A WQUICK 1-0
3:23 OF IT AT FIVE EY'RE TRYING
PUCK AGAIN GOES RIGHT TO
THE FRONT OF THE NET, A NICE
DEFLECTION,  OF THE LEG ON
E
SCREEN.
PAVELSKI BACKHANDS.
SPINS IT OD THEYA CLOSE ESH L
DIFFICULT CALL IS -- AND THE PL.
SPOT. GOING TO GET
>> Brendan: BUNCHED UP AT THE
SIDE OF NET AND A LITTLE
CARELESS P
STRUGGLING.
>> Darren: AND TKACHUK.
JAKE OETTINGER.
THERE WILL BE NOE POST THAT
OETTINGER NEVER SAW.
>>W HE'S GOT HIS HEAD UP,
LOOKING AROUNDT SHIFT.
>> Butch: DALLASS ANALYST, YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THTHI THINK THAT GO
SAYING.
>> Brendan: 30 SECONDS COACH,
2,70
SCORE!
JOE PAVELSKI!
AN
THE REBOUND'S ON THE DOORSTEP
AND PAVELSKI BANGS, THEY JUST
TWO YEARS AGO INR BI THERE IN TH
>> Brendan: PAVELSKI, SCORE ON
THE PO
MARKSTROM ALL GAME LONG AND HI
MOVE THAT ONE.
OR KEEP IT
>> GREAT
GOING TO BE THERE, ESPECIALLY
WITH
SCORES BEFORE BREAKAWAY ON
THE TWIG OF JOHNNY HOCKEY.
HE'S JUST NOT ABLE TO ELEVATE IT
OVER THE TOP